- All right y'all,
I wanna close out with a video
that's had a lasting impact on
me and some of my staff here.
This is what I'm liking.
Before the break,
we were celebrating spring and
maybe no one is more relieved
for some sunshine than this kid.
News cameras caught him hard at work
after a snowstorm in
Toronto earlier this year.
- If you didn't have a machine to help you
move the snow, you probably found it a bit
- Tiring. Ugh.
- A snow day turned into a
work day for Carter Trozzolo.
- I really wish I was in school right now.
- Trozzolo was clearing snow around
not just his house, but also doing it.
- For my neighbors, friends,
probably people I even don't know.
(laughing and cheering)
- It's so amazing.
It's like a skip
Little Carter's sigh might
have been quiet and amazing
but it was a sigh heard around the world.
In fact, that video's right
up more than 15 million views
and it helped Carter help
his neighbors even more.
We have him on the line right
now watching on City TV.
What's up Carter.
- Hi.
- Oh my gosh.
I wish you were here.
I wanna hug you so hard.
You're so cute.
So Carter, how happy are you
that the snow season is over?
- I'm pretty happy Kelly,
shoveling that snow was
really exhausting.
- I love you.
So the snow was really bad
that day, though, right?
That was deep.
- Yeah. The biggest snow
storm I've seen in Toronto
I was, at the start
I was pretty happy that the
school day was canceled.
And, but after a little while I got bored.
So I asked my mom, what should I do?
And my mom said, I should
go and shovel outside
'cause I've been doing
it for a couple of years
to help the community.
And so I did, maybe an
hour and a half later,
I'm finishing up and a news reporter comes
up to me and starts asking me questions.
And by then I was extremely exhausted.
(laughing)
- I know one thing to know Carter,
never tell your parents you're bored.
'Cause we will, we will find
something for you to do.
I love that you're like one
of the only kids on the planet
that's like I miss school right now.
So why do you think people
loved your video much,
And what's happened since then?
- I think they liked it
because we're all exhausted from either
COVID, work, isolation,
or other things that I have no idea about.
And I know how they feel
'cause I am always exhausted.
- Oh my God, Carter,
come back on our show.
Just every age of your life,
I just wanna see what's hap--
I wanna know you as an adult one day.
Carter, you are so funny.
Oh, your parents must be hilarious.
I'm liking your post right now.
We all love you for this.
And that's not all, my man,
our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion, the go to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson
show, want to celebrate
those creating fearlessly
or helping out their
community, just like you.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
See it was worth it.